two one nine two david p is our
voicemail number here's a voicemail
accusing me of not knowing that the word
to legitimate is false take a listen to
this i just David hunter from Lake
Harmony Pennsylvania um I just want to
let David know that there is no world
legitimates the word is legitimize
legitimizes anyway my mighty temptin
yeah well those are your two cents
here's my two cents and that is that I'm
putting up on the screen for you the
dictionary definition of to legitimate
as a verb
the adjective legitimate means that it
conforms to the law or two rules but of
course there is a definition of the word
spelled the same way but it is
pronounced legitimate which is a verb
and it is to make legitimate to justify
or make lawful for example the regime
was not legitimated by popular support
so David I appreciate your two cents and
I am returning those two cents or at
least a different two cents of mind to
you and telling you that the word to
legitimate as I used it is correct and
because of that I have no time to tell
you what's on the bonus show but trust
me folks it's a good one